j'ai voulu vérifier si vous c'est
vraiment des vedettes sa copie donc
j'étais rencontré quelques spectateurs
seniors pour tester votre notoriété
seniors j'ai une chance seniors seniors
genre isabelle ou seniors dans beau
c'est quoi il est méchant
ah oui ils sont très très vivant à bon
et comme ça suffisait pas j'aurais fait
croire que cette année on n'avait pas le
budget pour garder tout le monde
donc je leur ai demandé de m'aider à
faire un choix entre certains ne prenez
pas perso ça va secouer un peu
c'est notre focus groupes allaient en
découdre à quoi ça ressemble vous
proposer de participer à une étude sur
des personnalités de la télé la première
question je vais vous poser déjà
est ce que vous connaissez ces personnes
oui oui c'est par ces conditions
certes elle dit mais chez rencast a dit
casser les mots confirme être mais sa
place n'est pas là elle est où sa place
à l'est puis je la verrais plutôt dans
le cinéma dans le cinéma c'est à dire
c'est à lui de son père et à droite
c'est le maire le maire et michel michel
lemaire oui c'était 4 pas s'arrêter ou
pas où cette personne à être connus et
inconnus en plus dans tout domaine tout
de même de rennes privés élus et
professionnels
parce qu'ici que non artistique
[Musique]
il n'existe pas voilà c'était jean
michel mr d'accord n'avait jamais
entendu parler de jean michel maire ça
ne dit rien non moi je connais pas mais
je trouve qu'il a tout à fait le
physique ou pour faire de la télé ou
pour être artiste
je viens est ravie au théâtre alors en
fait c'est ce sont deux chroniqueurs de
touche pas à mon poste
cette année il ya une réorganisation et
on resserre des équipes
si vous devez choisir entre les deux
vous choisissez lequel je crois soirée
monsieur f ceccaldi ceccaldi je me suis
là parce que disons que j'ai vu
plusieurs fois dans les pays cités c'est
ça ce que vous aimez chez lui c'est les
publicités père d'emma plusieurs qui
nous lâchent est ce que comme ça comment
il est connu
kassali les fans il arrive à la télé
pour tous que le travail sur tf1 il a
fait exactement moi s'il aura un choix à
faire
j'enlèverai les deux procédés qui est le
plus timide a ni l'autre 1 michel
bernard ancien bernard bernard montfort
exactement était ce qu'ils font là du
sport d'accord et la personne de gauche
qui dirait qu'il ressemble à jean phi
aujourd'hui c'est bien alors je suis de
gauche c'est ça c'est ce qu'ils disent
big sister comment vous avez comment
était son expression orale
il a dit que cette star de télé ben
écoute cas il faudrait que tu grand
risque parce que là je te reconnais pas
assise et une star de la télévision ou
dans la bonneterie connaîtrait et puis
on le ferait beaucoup plus qu'on le voit
dans ce moment quant à l'autre il
appelait le charisme henri arnauld
bernard montiel a plus de charisme que
matri de l'ombre de mon côté c'est vrai
que je les ai vus plusieurs fois dans
tes mpp non c'est raté aucun cas pas la
même expérience que bernard montiel donc
on garde qui moi j'irai celui internat
mondial dames entière de leur nom il
admire alors que bernard montiel has
been ah oui carrément
et vous voudriez m ou si vous l'enlever
de pékin c'est un professionnel la
droite à gauche c'est un gars qui il
sort de l'école quoi ouais c'est ça
c'est ça on ressent câble ouais c'est un
bleu pas exactement un bonhomme
alors vous
non j'ai patrouillé sur les deux
personnes en france qui ne connaissent
pas de magasin au nom
je vais vous dire la vérité on a coupé
plein de gens montage parce qu'il est
trop dur qui vous connaissais pas là on
a pris ce qui vous connaissez le mieux
voilà quelques sacs albi vous appelle
ceccaldi est ce que ça vous arrive ça
dans la victoire oui ça m'est arrivé
mais c'est un c'est un comédien
oui c'est quasi un grand comédien bien
toi mais je m'en sors pas trop mal
profond ce travail quand je sors pas
beaucoup mieux de leur mort déjà mata
côté de montiel c'était déjà une
perfidie aurait ce n'était pas maire
bernard montiel respectent mutuellement
bernard montfort du sport tellement fait
une autre génération
alors est ce que les autres ont un petit
commentaire là dessus moi je trouve que
c'est intéressant le rapport à la
célébrité en fait sort de ces les briefe
t on s'aperçoit qu'on pense à la tout de
suite des néologismes m ce qui est très
connu mais comme de toute façon les
réseaux sociaux c'est une bulle
spéculative
en fait on s'aperçoit que les vrais gens
ne le connaissent pas parce que moi les
gens qui me connaissent et pas des bras
des jambes assez défoulant
juste un vol de nuit comme ça c'est
clair les lumières c'est clair les mêmes
ça c'est la lumière automatique du frigo
tu m'as dis donc pendant la diffusion du
reportage qu'il était très connu mais
l'international
vous n'êtes pas dans mon pays c'est bête
a vu que les trois scènes vous devriez
dans les duty free
quels sont les aéroports et que les
autres fallait malin parce qu'il n'y
avait même pas la matière pour les
mettre dans le sujet à l'ailé gainey et
autres je sais pas qui a voulu voir la
chasse
[Applaudissements]
merci ils m'amènent comme ça en
transition je voulais voir la suite du
faux culs secondes alors isabelle vous
écris verges avant demain consensus
contre la somme de courriers que je
reçois au nom de morandini dubosc
tellement je suis moche mais tout le
temps tout on y vient je voulais
vraiment il aurait vraiment dit ni du
boss la voix si tout sera là pour vous
laquelle est la plus connue des deux
plutôt celle de gauche et celle de
gauche vous l'avez vu dans l'émission et
mpp isabelle dubosc les abbesses dubosc
moi ni mort ni du buzz pardon c'est
important de préciser est par contre 7,2
droite le visage est trop en marqueterie
par par le maquillage le rouge à lèvres
si une personne qui vit là dessus elle a
trop de maquillage et vision sur la
personne attendait s'appelle géraldine
marteau pour le camping moyet mallet
géraldine maillet je pensais que c'est
une invitée d'après-vous ils font quoi à
part être connus que dans la vie vous
les imaginez comment celle de droite
doit pas être coiffeuse et ça veut dire
quoi bon cheval vous avez passé coupe de
cheveux pour trouver et déjà on voit
trop trop le maquillage vous énervez pas
moi c'est vrai qu'il est maquillée
quesada clair un regard de laquelle
celle de gauche qui s'appelle mal et non
voilà c'est morini-bosc mouskouri fusée
de gauche la nouvelle
la nouvelle wii gérance montaner sa
carrière je pense qu'elle est plus
derrière que devant un
c'est triste à dire mais c'est la
réalité aussi je sais pas si on va le
garder ça pour passer à la suite est ce
que vous les connaissez verbales envers
deux fils gilles à il vous plaît
visiblement j'ai bon il n'y a pas de
façon de réflexion est née je n'ai pas
trop grande gueule s'il est bien trop
longue
bonjour et aux heureux est celui de
gauche j'aurais vu plusieurs fois
pendant touche pas à mon poste
et on appelle aussi tpp les paroles de
la jeune fille a droit qu est-ce que
vous la connaissez ces données il sent
qu'elle a fait une émission sur l'a6
décor un appartement dans le genre comme
ça c'est valérie damidot voilà c'est
celle que vous dira que nous avons fait
moins de maturité et la jeune fille à
droite on veut pas la rencontre et où j
tout à fait pour gilbert conneries au
visage jolie fille donc s'ils ont dû
regarder un des deux géants les de la
gauche saborit tonnes elle est une
dernière question là là c'est
particulier parce que vous connaissez la
jeune fille
elle s'appelle justin justin bieber on
voit que c'est une personne qui souhaite
surtout que très bien et on voit que
huit âgés bien et bien ribéry
elle a un visage libéré moi je vais vous
délivrer merci bon il dit
merci beaucoup a été servi
alors on est bien chez vous recevoir